it's a battle of Big Ideas President
Trump and 2020 Democrats clashing on key
issues in the fight for the White House
first up immigration the Trump
administration says it's taking a big
step toward ending catch-and-release by
scrapping the Florez agreement which
limits the amount of time migrant
families can be detained Trump also
saying he could end birthright
citizenship watch this we're looking at
that very seriously birthright
citizenship where you have a baby in our
land you walk over the border have a
baby congratulations the baby is now a
US citizen we're looking at it very very
seriously it's frankly ridiculous of
course 2020 Democrats are short on
actual solutions but have plenty of
insults for President Trump and they're
getting an assist from the media check
it out
this president is absolutely determined
to carry out maximum cruelty with little
children poor Brown they would rip kids
from the bosoms of their mothers it's a
ridiculous notion to overturn the 14th
amendment it's racist on its face he's
trying to drive us apart make us angry
immigrant families and specifically kids
they'll be held literally indefinitely
at the pleasure of the Trump
administration it's kind of like
Guantanamo everything about immigration
he's done to try to scare people is it
literally like what about those lucky
babies so lucky to be Americans you know
what the amazing part of it I looked at
the numbers and do you know a quarter of
a million babies are born in the United
States who are at so-called anchor
babies and the cost of this country is
two and a quarter billion dollars to the
hospitals to subsidize them which we end
up paying for but let me explain
something about the law it's real simple
all right it's not clear the 14th
amendment makes it very clear that you
are a citizen if you are someone who was
in the United States and is subject to
the jurisdiction thereof the key case
I'm not going to get into the weeds is
some was that Harris
okay but the key case involved an
individual whose parents were Chinese
and he was born in the United States
while they were here and they wouldn't
let him back in when he left the country
and the Supreme Court the United States
Supreme Court said look here's a bottom
line his parents had a legal right to be
here when they worked here and therefore
we're gonna let him be a citizen he was
born here they have never actually
answered the question which is on
everyone's minds right now and that is
can you become a citizen if your mother
is nine months pregnant jumps over the
wall and gives birth yeah and one the
author of the Fourteenth Amendment
senator said that it was primarily
directed at slaves it was not discussing
illegal immigrants or sons and daughters
of ambassadors from other countries
justice Watters I guess you're having an
argument the Supreme Court because the
Supreme Court has ruled on this issue I
know you just keep talking and hurting
yourself but I'm just saying feel fine
what you have is Republicans who have
said one the president shouldn't be
discussing this because he can't do it
by executive order they don't approve of
that and secondly that there's
established law here Supreme Court law
not lower courts the Supreme Court has
said under the Fourteenth Amendment a
child born in the United States is an
American citizen it's not subject to
debate but the larger point here is
about immigration the president
continues to go after and try to
demonize immigrants in this country as
the political stir for his base you know
to me today I saw that his numbers and
the AP pulls down to 36 percent approval
and he is looking for anything anything
that he can to find a way to gin up
support you know he doesn't have any
ideas on immigration he had been doing
is no ideas he has talking about for
three years you've been talking every
five minutes his idea his only idea has
been build a wall and that he hasn't
even gone there all right
here's the issue that's the real problem
and it's not just with immigration it's
also with homelessness and other
problems that we that afflict our
society the left adheres to one singular
strategy and that is any kind of process
any kind of law any kind of logic or any
kind of reason is it is a symptom of
cruelty you will be accused of
demonizing if you want to help the
homeless off the street you demonize if
you want to if you want to enforce your
border you demonize this only happens
though when the other side is in charge
right when the Republicans in charge
once the Democrats in charge then they
start acting like adults President Obama
acted like an adult when he was saying
the very same things that President
Trump is border policy like a lot of
things in life requires a process a
system which entails rules and
enforcement adults get this the media
and the Dems who you cannot tell the
difference when you do that montage you
couldn't tell which one was in the media
which one was running for president
because there precisely the same animal
and I mean animal purely as a metaphor I
think I have to raise my voice to make
my point here but well this is the five
[Laughter]
actual words of quote-unquote Obama guys
remember the president referred to the
acting DHS secretary MacLennan went on
America's newsroom yesterday morning
nine didn't even by the way Jesse he
said this is a significant step at a
significant step at addressing the core
aspect of the crisis at the border
Obama's former but border patrol chief
mark Morgan was on this morning said
this is a game changer this will
absolutely eliminate at least part of
the border crisis but you go back rewind
one year ago when Jay Johnson the Obamas
one DHS secretary made the point that
the Flores is an issue they ran into
this this was a problem this is a
loophole that has to be closed but also
want to address the media talking about
this indefinite period of time that
these migrants can be detained
indefinitely more true lling 2001 180
days is the longest period of time so
realistically speaking they're talking
about a 50 to 60 day time period that
they need to properly process these
migrants watch the table should be how
do we properly process
deal with the fact that we have on the
books asylum law Sondra and we want it
in fact hold to the law Greg talks about
let's do everything by the books by the
law the president has no ideas he had
the house three or four illegal
immigration they should do things but
know it's against the law crossing the
border